[Música]
el presidente de ecuatoriano guillermo
lasso rindió ayer martes ante la
asamblea de ese país el informe de su
primer año de gestión con la promesa de
luchar contra la inseguridad construir
miles de viviendas y también poner en
marcha el sector productivo de ese país
laso aseguró que en los últimos 12 meses
se empeñó en poner en equilibrio en las
cuentas fiscales en referencia al alto
endeudamiento de más de 60 por ciento de
producto interno bruto y un déficit
fiscal que llegó a alcanzar el 10 por
ciento en cuanto a la inseguridad
aseguró que
entiende que el temor de la población
sea de esta manera pero aseveró que va a
enfrentar a las organizaciones
criminales a los narcotraficantes y
también a los que trafican personas y al
tráfico de armas señaló que está en
marcha la creación de un nuevo modelo de
gestión para así recuperar el poder del
estado en las cárceles y descongestionar
el hacinamiento a través de la concesión
de indultos y la aceleración de los
procesos judiciales que están pendientes
para ello entonces quiero saludar a
nuestro primer invitado del día el de
santiago
basabé politólogo y docente asociado de
ciencia política de la facultad
latinoamericana de ciencias sociales
gracias a santiago por estar con
nosotros en directo américa de france 24
por supuesto le pregunto entonces el
balance general de lo que ha sido este
primer año de guillermo lazo frente al
poder frente a ecuador
bueno y gracias buen día yo creo que hay
dos cosas que son los más relevantes la
primera evidentemente es la vacunación
ecuador ha sido de los países con los
mayores de éxitos al menos a nivel de la
región me atrevería a decir a nivel del
mundo también en el plano del control de
la vacunación de la extensión de las de
la vacunación y de tomar medidas de
restitución a la a la cotidianidad y eso
me parece que es algo inobjetable
incluso por la oposición el segundo tema
que yo creo que el gobierno ha manejado
bastante bien hasta ahora es el tema
fiscal el tema el tema económico del
país las cifras macroeconómicas han
mejorado en buena medida hay una mayor
mejor y mayor relación con los
organismos multilaterales de crédito se
ha descendido en alguna medida a la
enorme brecha fiscal que teníamos y yo
creo que el país en ese sentido tiene
buenas noticias pero del otro lado
evidentemente en el balance negativo yo
creo que hay una deuda social muy
importante del gobierno que el
presidente ha dicho ayer que se va a
comprometer a asumir en este segundo año
y me refiero específicamente a la
provisión de servicios básicos del país
requiere muchísima inversión en el plano
de la educación por en el plano de la
salud y evidentemente en el plano de la
seguridad esa ha sido la apuesta del
presidente del día de ayer
termine de arreglar en alguna medida el
tema financiero fiscal y ahora en este
segundo momento voy al tema social vamos
a ver si es que eso se ve decir ahora
santiago vamos a hablar del tema de la
seguridad que ha estado deteriorado
últimamente en el ecuador cómo está a
nivel general la seguridad del ecuador y
también por supuesto hablemos de la
crisis carcelaria y las matanzas digamos
los
enfrentamientos entre los reos que se
han presentado en estos últimos meses
bueno el tema de la inseguridad es
enorme en el país o sea debe ser el
problema más importante la gente incluso
por encima del trabajo en muchas
encuestas plantea el tema de la
seguridad que es un tema que yo creo que
con el gobierno del señor lazo sale a la
luz es un tema que viene arrastrando el
país al menos una década que no fue
controlado a su debido momento y que
ahora tener unos problemas enormes
después organizada del narcotráfico la
penetración del narcotráfico tengo la
impresión cada vez es más ya no sólo a
nivel delincuencial sino incluso en
espacios de la política lo cual es muy
grave y esperemos que el gobierno pueda
tomar cartas en el asunto frente a un
problema insisto que viene de mucho
tiempo atrás y que seguramente le va a
costar muchísimos recursos económicos
poder enfrentarlo porque los temas de
seguridad en cualquier país del mundo
implican recursos económicos y muchos
además ojalá el gobierno tenga los los
restos y los recursos para poder
enfrentar este tema porque como he dicho
seguramente es él el que más agobia a la
población ahora mismo y también digamos
hablemos santiago el de la seguridad
ciudadana como está en materia de
seguridad ciudadana las calles ecuador
yo creo que es variopinto hay ciudades
son un poquito más peligrosas me refiero
a guayaquil por ejemplo aquí con las dos
más pobladas de las ciudades más
pequeñas de los problemas son menores en
todo esto responde a lo que mencionado
un problema estructural de largo plazo
pero responde también a la ausencia de
capacitación profesional tecnológica y
de recursos humanos de la policía
nacional cada vez es más notorio que la
delincuencia le desbordó a la policía la
policía es incapaz de poder resolver el
tema por sí mismo por estas deficiencias
anotadas insisto sobre todo en las
ciudades más grandes guayaquil equipos
balance en su política exterior la
política exterior en ese primer año que
ha sido el gobierno del presidente
guillermo lasso
bueno ha tenido dos cancilleres el
primero un canciller de carrera que
reordenó en la academia diplomática que
reordena el ministerio tiene ahora un
canciller que es más una cuota política
yo creo que él en términos generales la
agenda internacionales es positiva el
gobierno ha retomado sus relaciones con
varios países con las cuales tenía
ciertas distancias se ha mejorado mucho
la relación con colombia por ejemplo que
es nuestro vecino natural y por tanto es
un país clave como cualquier en
cualquier otro contexto en cualquier
otro país el ecuador ha conseguido
avanzar en algunos proyectos de cara a
la apertura económica hay críticas
respecto a cómo se ha avanzado a los
pasos que se han dado y eso puede ser un
punto en contra pero me parece que en
términos generales la imagen del país en
el contexto internacional va en mejora y
ojalá esto se pueda mantener en el
tiempo que otras cosas a santiago usted
pues también como ecuatoriano pudiera
resaltar no también decir estoy en
desacuerdo con lo que ha hecho el
presidente guillermo lazo que dicen los
ciudadanos en ecuador digamos como en la
popularidad del presidente guillermo
lasso en este año
bueno ayuda en descenso ha ido en
descenso a pesar de tener un resultado
enormemente positivo en el tema de la
vacunación ha ido en descenso y me
parece que la razón de fondo y esta es
una de las mayores críticas
generalizadas es que la política de
comunicación del gobierno ha sido muy
deficiente no no existe una estructura
orgánica para comunicarle a la población
la población se entera de los temas de
forma aislada no hay un vocero único y
me parece que esa ha sido una de las
deficiencias más importantes y eso se
refleja precisamente en ese deterioro de
la aceptación popular